en replay du coup bah je vais arriver
juste un petit peu en dedans le stream
donc les premières minutes on va
attendre que les gens arrivent d'un tout
petit peu en avance parce que j'ai envie
de vous demander ce que vous avez envie
de faire ce que vous avez envie de voir
donc je vais me vais ouvrir le chat de
la chase comme tv une nouvelle fois
justin fait pas mal de trucs à fait des
parties pédagogie ni qu'on a essayé on a
aussi essayé quoi on a aussi essayé la
l'entraîneur tactique et du coup tu vois
la question que je me pose c'est qu'est
ce qu'on a envie de de faire et ce qu'on
a des idées des des choses qui vous ont
qu'ils ont plus fait pas des idées mais
des choses qui vont non plus par le
passé je cherche mais parce que je en
train d'ouvrir autre chose sur
l'ordinateur donc le chat
et oui donc s'y est ce que vous avez
envie de revoir qu'on fasse des partis
ensemble ont peut-être pas aussi
pédagogique que l'adf on va se réserver
pour une soirée spéciale mais des partis
avec vous on a aussi la possibilité de
refaire un peu des tactiques
je vais prendre pour le moment un défi
et puis je voulais c'est un peut
répondre je vois qu'il ya des gens qui
sont déjà arrivés dans le tchat
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus plu donc
elliott alors allez on va lui en faut 20
ans et j'ai cats quand même s'ils jouent
contre nous ils avaient envie de se
prendre un g4 on sait que tu as envie de
te prendre g4 tonton on le sait gibbons
soir à tout le monde
waouh ce qui fait d'eux voulait voir des
bulles est d'ailleurs alors que ni merci
pour la vidéo avec va doit surtout merci
à vlad un merci à vlad plus qu'à plus
qu'à moi même
cette dame madame ici qui peut être
pénible
allez on va essayer de jouer de manière
très périlleuse on va essayer de
s'amuser un petit peu on se retrouve
avec une pièce deux mois on va faire
tomber notre adversaire allait on va se
faire plein on va prélever près vous
prêt move on va le mettre en pls parce
qu'on peut le maté au centre de
l'échiquier
si je préfère quil va laisser cette
maths ça me plairait mais je peux pas
pour le moment on va faire 4 à lui
redonner un pion je vais essayer de le
mater de jolie manière
et voilà je voulais faire qualifier
cette mater on a réussi sa chaîne qui
est très content du retour de vlad part
est ce que ce sera un bon retour ou pas
on ne sait pas un joli matt elliott
désolé où est leur lancée lors de la
plaidoirie lors le big boss qui par jean
il te dire désolé pour le mat je ne
voulais pas quoi excuse moi je ne
voulais pas te mater aussi viola moi je
vais faire deux trois bulles est pour
voir ce que ça donne et je voulais c'est
essayer ou là j'ai des petits problèmes
de connexion je sais qu'il ya rejouer
très mal
enfin très mal non j'ai pas si mal joué
j'exagère un peu mais je n'étais pas au
top
alors on a une partie qui se lancent à
l'effet crise et 3 ont valu faire
cavalier seul [ __ ]
on va ranger le cavalier on va jouer un
joueur de française avec le fou qui peut
sortir puisqu'on n'a pas développé le
pion ça c'est toujours cool de jouer une
française avec le foie angers 4 je
reviendrai là dessus puisque c'était
intéressant
comme quoi même dans les bulles est
parfois on peut trouver un peu de
pédagogie j'aurais peut-être dû prendre
et faire cavalier e 7 h 5 pour empêcher
à l'adversaire de jouer gilles catoire
mettre le pion h4 parce que ça mange pas
de pain c'est bien joué de sa part
on va échanger les dames va accepter les
changes si le fait non ils échangent pas
les dames on écoute on n'est pas super
bien
on aime assez mal mon essayer de
survivre sur peut-être du alan b 7 pour
avoir décidé avec d'alger de maths
[Musique]
si on prend on avait des problèmes
je met le pion h3 ça mange pas de pain
je cède rauque et maintenant ok dexia
auquel j'ai plus de temps
maintenant il va pas prendre
ok
on va arriver où on voulait
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir prendre à deux
des fous ces cinq échecs mais j'ai pas
eu le temps de paix d'alger de maths et
ben voila c'était de la pédagogie ou a
donc je voulais juste revenir sur un
truc mais je dois prendre des leçons je
veux juste revenir sur un truc
ouais alors ok juste pour vous montrer
bon je sais pas si ça vous intéresse un
dites moi dans le chatt j'aime bien
avoir des retours chat là quand on fait
des partis comme ça j'aime bien avoir
plus de retours chat ça est-ce que
puisque c'est de la merde dans le sens
les trucs pédagogique mais j'ai envoyé
en fait l'idée dé 5,5 cavalières et
cavaliers g8 du coup en fait c'est pas
un coup si idiot pourquoi parce qu'après
des 4 c 5
vous allez avoir on retombe dans un truc
comme ça on retourne dans de 4,6 d4 d5
est eux qui peuvent jouer blanche veut
s'arrêter là vous remarquez que si on
joue ces cinq les blancs vont jamais
joué cavalier c3 si vous connaissez un
petit peu il joue généralement assez pas
obligé on peut aussi jouer les systèmes
à 4,4 dont joue généralement plutôt c3
pour maintenir le centre n'est pas
complètement vrai ce que je suis en
train de dire mais c'est pour faire
simple et du coup le problème de la
française c'est le foot bloquant ses
huit ça vous le savez je lui rabâche et
redit d'ironie vous le savez est donc en
fait du coup quand tu écris ces trois
cavaliers 6e 4 des 5 e 5 qualifiés 8 des
quatre d'un côté j'ai perdu deux temps
avec lecavalier
donc c'est à ces points négatifs mais
point positif c'est que quand je fais
ces cinq déjà je le mets tout de suite
la pression sur le centre et qu'il a
passé 3 est deuxième point positif
peut-être qu'il doit jouer un système
avec des français plus tôt c'est que
quand il va mettre le cavalier en f3 si
le métro taux bas je pourrais jouer au
foot et 4 et quelque part pour régler
les problèmes du fou du coup ça
ressemble un peu plus peut-être à une
carreaux cannes variante d avance
donc voila c'était pour expliquer est
vite fait ce que j'appelle de la
pédagogie de comptoir en gros de la
merde alors crois pas qu'il y ait des 7
à près de 5 ce que sa part des deux
pions des 5 de la croix bon alors on
vous contraint m nationale donc
automatiquement j'ai envie de dire on se
sent bien on va les jouer la classique 1
mais il prend le fou vas-y bien bien
bien bouffer ok je farfouille 5 pour le
monde alors pas l'air d'être très très
fort ce que je fais pour le moment mais
c'est marrant fait ça je pense qu'il
peut prendre maintenant
mais juste alma un peu en paix alès
c'est ce qui est drôle
on va pousser un c'est marrant il a même
pas pris du pillon qua non tu n'es
changera pas les dames dégage maintenant
tu ouvres ligne de vente aura fait gamme
très attention allez on va s'amuser on
va faire kf3 échec
lassé de la mise en pl est ce qu'on est
en train de faire allez hop on encaisse
ton pions parce qu'il ne sert à rien ton
fouet cloud et maintenant tu mets un
petit échec
on va te glisser la dame en d3 regarde
la dame elle était là maintenant elle
vient là on va te mettre une torah
schmitt bon on va revenir par ici voit
peut-être pas la gagner on se serait
amusé c'est pas très efficace la manière
de jouer mais bon ça devrait passer
ça c'était anticipé cet échec hop hop
hop
hop voilà l'adversaire joue vite mais
bon tu as plus de gaz pour ton grave
comme très attention à elle est rapide 1
le volkan explorer explorer de volcans
sais je suis en volcan j'explore fait
quand même très attention à ce que tu es
en train de te prendre de la lave dans
la gueule des gages
je garde mes foot est un jeu on va lui
tenter à l'ancienne avec le fourrage
sept des familles là le truc qui marche
pas trop normalement on va essayer de
l'attenté à l'ancienne c'est une zone tu
n'auras jamais mon foot qu'à second je
peux enfin julien faut le savoir quand
tu dégages
cavalia 3 je me développe sur les bords
fait très attention
bon ben maintenant jeu rock band il
vient prendre l'option est bien bouffe
ça c'est très bien comme on l'a on est
tombé sur un mec est bon il veut tout
bouffer alors à bondoukou fait champions
c'est 7 et on va les finir
c'est à des enfants qui regardent ce que
je fais ne marche pas absolument pas je
préfère le dire parce que vous pourrez
être tenté tout est pareil ce que je
fais dans cette partie est absolument
pourri alors le problème c'est qu'il ya
rien qui marche on va planter le fou on
fait quand même très attention à ton
fief est dans ma came as mince
c'était pas loin de passer ils veulent
changer les dames ont mal en est foutu
aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe quel dommage s'est pas passé
allez c'est parti on va jouer un peu
plus sérieusement maintenant
trêve de plaisanterie tonton bouger 4 tu
dégages
mais parce qu'on jouait pas sérieux
avant tu allons contacter à laisser
vivre
on a laissé vivre volkan explorer fait
quand même très très attention
on va faire un échec
on a laissé vivre maintenant il est
temps de 2 tab à 3 le new deal fait
petit rock aïe aïe aïe mes amis aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe
mais bon le roi le roi vian et fuite
c'est une case c'est une case grobet ce
qu on va dégager avec ton fou bon c'est
quand même très content de faire des
pions de triplés donc on va pas faire
passer la balle à faire une vraie mise
en pls je pense qu'aux échanges et les
dames on va la voir à son propre jeu
je défends qui ont littéralement fait
attention on se passe super après répond
je prends moi je viens là tout le monde
t5 c'est un peu chaud encore les tontons
je défends allez hop je vais me matter
je vais tenter de le mater
c'était tellement dans l'esprit cette
tentative de maths
maintenant je perds ce pion quelle
horreur est alors envoyé les rapides un
voyage oublie-t-il 8 bon j'ai compris
tombé sur un mec qui était très fort
quand ça a joué vite c'est par oral mais
trempé alès vous inquiétez pas j'ai
aucune peur de ce joueur je comprends
tout à fait à qui j'ai affaire c'est un
monstre de vitesse en gros c'est un bon
mec pour faire des pls je pense même si
pas forcément méga forme donc ça va être
chaud mais je sens qu'on peut le faire
faut qu'on joue des trucs très con je
pense je pense que ça peut marcher
voilà on pousse tous nos pions 1 c'est
le v de la victoire fait très attention
et à boom dégage
[Musique]
bon je vais faire ce moyen là et on va
pousser
mais j'en ai vu faire une vieille paire
est sage père le fou c'est vrai que
c'est que j'ai envie de faire de faire
les choses beau de faire les choses
belles quoi j'ai envie de faire des
belles attaques de maths des beaux trucs
mais le mont joux a pas assez les
tactiques je vois pas assez vite les
tactiques j'ai envie de le mater à la
brutale de faire vraiment n'importe quoi
trajet tout reprend 1,5 mais je rate des
trucs simples
ouais faut que je m l'autopromo aussi
mince je vais faire rager trois premiers
boum boum boum le petit matin à
l'ancienne qui tenait en pls vas-y
revient vulkan up g5 dégage
bon assez cool c'est cool on va lui
donner un peu des pions ça va lui faire
les pieds nadi bouffe on va se faire
bouffer des pions tu as affaire grand
roque évidemment coup là ils attaquent à
damas tension allait bien
on va prendre va prendre partout on va
pousser au centre maintenant allez on se
bat on va écouter un on a déjà fait
cette erreur quand on a mis des pls de
paas et échanger les dames on va pas la
refaire alors la laisser doubler comme
un idiot vas-y vas-y fais féret dia
musso avec des tours c'est de la merde
de toute façon mais voilà donc d4 je
dois tu dégages avec ce pion tu va
dégager avec celui-là
maintenant on va protéger le foie font
enfin un échec pour te faire les pieds
on va barrer avec ça
le truc c'est que tu as un poil lent
vrai ça me fait marrer cette position
allez hop il est tombé joue à lille
matin avec le pion à deux en fait allez
revient g4 un bon bah écoute 1 on va te
donner du matériel on va te pousser
l'option dessus fait qu'un très
attention à ses lampions de la grogne
s'est jamais tu ne toucheras quoi c'est
le pion glamour fait très attention
c'est très glamour comme si on regarde
boom f4 jeu j'avance tous les pions
notre bâtiment le pion c'est de la merde
donc je suis prêt à le donner à l'ap va
faire flouer trois dames des deux grands
rock
bon bah dégage où va-t-on roi fait très
attention
on va lui faire recette va le défoncer
un séquence et quand il s'appelle volkan
explorer quel pseudo de merde au nom
n'est pas honnêtement enfin je sais pas
je sais je ne sais pas où tu es tombé
pour un pseudo comme ça quand ils volkan
explorer volcano explorer pardon non
mais l'histoire de volcans paf
bon allez va gagner la dame quand même
il vas y vas y vas gagner il va nous
reprendre du matos là vous quand même
très attention à ce que tu allais est
enfermée là il est bon pas c'est un
petit échec
on souhaite attaquer attention c'est
chaud c'est chaud
c'était un peu tactique on a perdu du
matos
non on se bat on est en train d'explorer
son volcan
ok volca drake sur la vie revient à il
veut plus jouer il veut plus jouer
vallecano explorer c'est quoi cette ps
ohlala non seulement ils arrivaient en
solo de merde non plus il se barre tout
de suite et ya google avec chrome qui
s'ouvre non mais bon enfin voilà un bref
on était à peine en train de se chauffer
la gt gt pachot fait dix minutes qu'on
joue on était en état en bas de 11
le tour de chauffe quand le mec fait une
sortie de piste direct on dirait
sébastien grosjean ou grand prix là
l'autre jour quand il quand il se fout
dans le mur au tour de chauffe
non mais franchement non mais
franchement volcano explorer là tu me tu
me déçois quoi bon alors est ce qu est
ce qui est une autre personne que
souhaite mettre en pls là que lui le
voile est ce pour ça qu'on peut pas
réussir les vidéos de péages ou dit que
c'est dur à filmer une vidéo de perez le
roi de la mise en place c'est que le mec
est en perez avant que tu vas avant
qu'on soit chaud j'ai même pas eu le
temps de sortir de punchlines encore
j'étais même pas encore chaud je vous
dis en plus je joue pas très bien ce
soir je sens que je vois pas les
tactiques je sens que je joue mal je
semble vous mal du coup pas si on va
tomber sur un adversaire aussi facile en
lui c'était quand même c'était quand
même un souffre-douleur quoi je pense
pas qu'on puisse retrouver sur quelqu'un
de signaux que le précédent
malheureusement
je pense pas surtout que j'aime pas du
tout la position que j'ai je fais un peu
de la merde on n'est pas tombé sur un
original le mec des échanges les dames
direct monkey hyper une qualité au
passage parce que bon il ne calcule pas
mais je sens le fourbe
si tu veux échanger des pièces échanges
qu'est ce que tu veux moi j'ouvre des
colonnes parce que j'ai une tour toi je
te préviens de ma stratégie en masse
tratégie cieux c'est ça tu as tes pas
tomber sur sur le nahd leonardo davinci
des échecs tu as envie de te dire
bon alors là tu veux faire kiev 4 mai à
tours prend b2 bon ok je finis par me le
faire planter évidemment mais c'est pas
très grave
à la rigueur
ouais t'es pas tomber sur lui l'honneur
de davinci des échecs
bon allez approuvé l'échangé
baic veuille jouer vite hockey balle et
tu veux jouer vite on joue vite aller
une robe alors le mec et coacher le mec
de zekri coach chicken alors lui c'est
un coach bon ben on va voir enfin cote
chez nous contre la montre la cropte
quoi s'il te plaît quoi fait nous cet
honneur que chicken yves que nous avons
besoin d'un coach que nous savons quoi
qu'on a joué contre la drogue jean-luc
te dire ta manière de coacher ça donne
pas très envie de ça rien tu avais mon
âge je les prends du cabba lazio a très
bien joué d'ailleurs pris du plomb
excellent coup mais kevin très très bien
joué bravo passé en ligne fait petit
rock bon écoute on va te laisser tenter
une découverte de merde c'est différent
une découverte coach allait coach c'est
pas de ma faute si le mec s'appelle
coach après les mecs un mois je ne peux
rien le mec veut nous coach évasif 1
ni deux nous quoi
coach moi quoi s'il te plaît bail mais
bon enfin bon vaty remésy coach vas-y
servi bouffe des pions en termes vifs et
très importe c'est très intéressant ça
comme courtier bouffe niveau bas mais
bon j'y peux rien quoi fin excuse moi
quoi
lady bouffe les pions et diffus tête une
fois en échec
ah mince fallait que je prenne le fou en
premier la duc on est dans la merde là
du coup coach va nous bat quoi une pièce
deux mois après mais on va se battre
je crois qu'après damas de je suis très
mal mais bon je monte quoi on va se
barrer
je peux en manger sain que je peux
apprendre cavaillon six échecs ok on
défend quoi aller coach montre nous ton
talent quoi il éblouit nous de
éclabousse nous de ta classe quoi fais
très attention je peux te m'attend c'est
un thème coach et moi je dis ça je dis
rien tu vois tension hta tour à coach
attention tu as tout re [ __ ] plus moi
je suis dit les coups tu vois je me dis
je veux pas je veux pas l'accabler et
tout tu vois je veux pas qu'ils passent
pour un coût battus à moi je suis moi je
suis dans une approche sympa tu vois
mehdi le mec il a rien demandé à
personne il se prend une pls voix voilà
peut-être nous faire tomber là quand
même
pas impressionnant tous à tonton pas
impressionnant tout ça je demande un
changement de pseudo après
non mais c'est désespérant non mais
vraiment été changé d'âme en toute
impunité contre une robe à la sortie
d'ouverture il a un pur - qua non mais
bon enfin j'en peux plus les mecs
nan je pars de mon fils qui est aussi
très attention moi ça s'était très
débile je range mes pièces fait très
attention
dégage je te coupe les oreilles tu n'as
plus d'oreilles en toi tu dégages aussi
aller à ya le pion qui tombe c'est de la
merde là on est très mal heureusement du
tour veut pas là nul il a un pion de
plus s'ils pensent qu'il peut la gagner
at il raison
il va me faire tomber ou pas qu'est ce
qu'il est nul quoi on a fait il faire
tourner a failli te le maté quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il est nul quoi aussi de
créer un nouveau défi qu'est ce qui se
passe à la mecque s'est barré oh lalala
lalala le mec s'est barré non mais c'est
pas possible les mecs j'en ai marre quoi
travaillent dans le chat il ya six
grandes scènes il est pas content quand
il comprend va y connais pas il connaît
pas le concept des pls quoi bon aller
urica une ponette hurricanes sera plus
fin allez on est reparti
on est reparti à ça va être tendu
je pense que lorsqu'il prend des 5 et
pranger 5h peut pas reprendre la a quand
même joué par un jeu de la part du riken
qui va s'échapper de justesse quand même
hein il sent il s'en sort et là on est
dans la merde
et là on est mal
il va faire des six ont accueilli 6,6
son sens ça pour le moment
malheureusement j'ai pas fou à 6 on est
malin
débarrasser de saddam ben ses fans comme
parti on va découvrir
on couvre on va finir par faire moi je
pense à
a bien joué bien joué ok je suis
toujours ici avec ma souris allez il
faut qu'il revienne c'est pas sûr qu'il
va y rejouer si l on va refaire une robe
à ces pages et cinq là dommage je
commence à me tromper dans la théorie
quoi bon va-t-il francs le pion les deux
ou pas
ah non plus faire des aveux qu'elle aura
si ce plan qui avec son roi c'est quand
même pas très chevaleresque tout ça et
c'est 4 c'est chiant il faut qu'on se
ressaisisse
il est peut-être dame prend 2,5 qui peut
marcher un moment donné
ben non
princesse va faire qui est b5
oula
je peux me faire contre matt et c'est
chaud
il ya dame prendre un vol à la cata je
peux pas avoir un math marrant un truc à
faire un truc joli nom bon pour moi
c'est plutôt à travers sac nouveau psg
enfin lutter
on a fait une partie marrante
mais m gagnant au final presque à y est
presque pas j'aurais pas eu le pion h
soirée fait patte
dommage dommage bon il ya l'adversaire
s'en va comme d'hab c'est insupportable
alors vas rejoint un peu normal dommage
fraudeurs adversaire 1 qu'est ce que
c'est que ça bon ça il mérite son petit
coup de pied bien là de me déstabiliser
ok il fait des coups pas forcément très
bon mais j'ai compris quoi ils jouent
assez vite et en bullet c'est pas
mauvais allons envoyer sur le roy
nansion fâche quatre équipes rendu foule
on s'en fout total on va faire à 4 quand
même on va prendre une fois la chanson
qui joue pas mal hein
toro 8 food et 8 et tout ça c'est très
changeant complètement foutu
bon
est ce qu'on a quelque chose et non on
n'a rien il ya juste puis on prend on
peut abandonner va fort se ressaisir
c'est très étrange
ok il ya des limites maths ou presque
alors ça je suis ronde et 1er mai que
j'avais vraiment la motive ils sont
barreto et a du coup ça fait un petit
coup de mou c'est dommage quoi on était
bien dans le truc mais c'est fatiguant
de faire un truc de pls et du coup plus
les adversaires passe plus c'est
difficile c'est pour ça qu'en juillet
que c'est difficile à tourner les vidéos
où je mets les inversions pls c'est tout
c'est exactement pour ça ce que vous
pouvez pas jouer beaucoup de parties
souvent les mecs se barre
et du coup après vous fatiguez vous
jouez moins bien est ce à dire
de plus en plus compliqué et donc c'est
très difficile à tourner
bon
pas l'air si mal a quand même
à pia ce que je fais
jeune importe quoi
ces plumes aux deux jours pourtant un
parti n'est pas difficile un lama fuite
quand même affaire fois ci c'est fou
prendrait sept matches pour le maté le
plus vite possible
bon ok mais je suis fait il fait exprès
de faire ça qu'est ce que tu sais ce
qu'ils disent est ce type je comprends
rien fait
c'est quoi le rapport la guilde ici on
va me faire écouter on prend perez
rapide
bon j'ai rien compris
non mais on peut plus après deux parties
qua non mais mais ces seniors quagmire
on met des semis perez enfin un hercule
poirot tient des bills a dit tout à
l'heure tu ne sais pas jouer va
apprendre les échecs m'a dit prends toi
j'ai quatre dans la gueule des gages
ok mais il faut toujours ce à quoi ils
arrêtent de jouer joue une partie jus de
partie s'arrête je sais très difficile
de faire des vidéos de ps c'est très
très difficile
les mecs sont tellement pls et telle
fragilité des adversaires si vous voulez
ces deux-là perez direct voilà on va lui
dombasle huit ans ps déjà une partie en
a perdu et les gens ps avec les blancs
il va pas jouer voilà on retrouve ces il
m'arrivait des fois une fois d'être
assis trois heures chez moi est pas
réussir à vous en faire une seule voix
la bombasse et ça va être ça tout le
temps amiens un allemand alors là on
s'attend quand même un petit peu plus de
résistance
on lui fait une borg j'espère en tout
cas je suis plus aux périodes s'il était
peut-être finlande et ou je sais pas
quoi ça fait quand même un peu résisté
quoi il y avait il y avait du répondant
ça fait plaisir
syfy carré lieu d'où on est tellement
mal
c'est à peu près après tous les coups
qu'on est super mal
bon truc ces vidéos de perez on peut pas
échanger les dames quoi sinon j'aurais
fait ou feront jour et c'est d'arnaqué
la finale mais là on n'est pas là pour
ça on est là pour jouer cette position
fantastique parce qu'il va trouver une
bonne découverte crois pas qu'il en est
bon allez on va se marrer alors mon
petit monsieur
et quand même très malin
à
c'est très intéressant on est tellement
mal c mais bon ils échangent les dames
il nous laisse survivre
du coup ils nous laissent nous la jouer
la montre
éventuellement
ah je suis parti du mauvais côté c'était
pas évident c'était pas évident avec peu
de temps à la pendule il a gagné la
première mais il n'a pas gagné la guerre
des fois c'est peut-être même mieux de
perdre la première pour les appâter un
peu parce que sinon ils partent trop
vite on va dire que c'est comme une
victoire pour vous
par contre qu'il va vouloir échanger les
dames tout le temps ça va ça va pas être
évident je me suis pas très bien
débrouillé là encore il va falloir jouer
un poil plus normal avant de repartir
dans le n'importe quoi sinon il va te
reprendre la confiance ça va être
horrible
il va te reprendre la confiance à être
horrible sinon vraiment tournicote un
peu ça j'avais pas vu
qui va falloir qu'on fasse mieux là
parce que je me fais trop dominer la
boum dans le bon tempo
mettre le feu en d5
à
aïe aïe aïe aïe le mec refuse de jouer
encore un mais c'est insupportable en
plus on a perdu deux parties quoi on a
perdu deux parties et fut la deuxième on
aurait dû le gagner je suis un peu lent
à la souris comme d'hab et le mec repart
une nouvelle fois dans l'essai c'est
tellement démotivant quoi pourtant le
mec est allemand quand on s'est dit on
est tombé sur un mec résistants banon
mais bon là on a gagné 2 donc
et en plus sa deuxième il la mérite pas
du coup nous a juste fait tomber quand
il était nettement perdant mais bon
bah c'est relou pour aller donc on
retourne contre des mecs titre et l'a
fait je voudrais jouer que contre des
mecs titre et pour que la paix à l'aise
soit belle et fallait cette partie h pas
du tout motivé quand même juste rien à
[ __ ] chercher un autre adversaire moi
aussi non mais bon ok c'est pour mettre
un mec comme ça en pls
quel intérêt quoi
allez jean une meuf non mais c'est
débile j'ai envie de me faire plein
j'aurais pu gagner une pièce en un coup
dans le hockey non mais bon ok c'est
juste il faut des mecs comme non pas de
revanche pour toi non mais les mac le
mac allemand va j'étais chaud et où je
m'étais dit je vais me chauffer gens
jouer 2 3 et ou pas on retombe sur le
même nom parce que c'est pas ça peut
être une petite mise en pls majeur c'est
pas ça pas le même charme
on fait des trucs beau après un rejet
revoilà regardez ces deux là après
quelque part ce qu'on fait non mais
c'est magnifique quoi
conceptuellement conceptuellement
parlant lasser c'est beau quoi j'ai
envie de chialer quand je vois un truc
comme ça j'ai envie de chialer je vois
une tour en achète moi ça ça me ça me
fait vibrer quoi
je suis presque envie de presque envie
de laisser en vie tu vois car il va
faire un tour et figé faire petit rock
tu vois non mais c'est dollars qu on a
tellement tout poussé devant notamment
tous poussés devant le roi confettis
rock s'est inversée
je trouve pas comment finir
oulala je suis en train de faire
n'importe quoi j'ai oublié ce truc là
aïe aïe aïe peut-être finir par la perte
du coup en essayant de faire de l'art
à
on n'avait plus qu'à essayer quand même
prendre leurs premiers mètres la tour
angers 6 pour lui enfermé saddam
c'est dommage qu'on ait plus de temps
parce que c'est beau quoi
bon plus on à la greffe mais bon ok
c'est pas un adversaire très intéressant
ok un maître international pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pour une belle ps
tu as tout ranger si c'est tout on n'est
plus assez temps et en plus on a la gué
à la fin je sens que on a en effet peu
de temps parce qu'on l'avait beaucoup
voilà j'ai pas fais et catalans mais je
suis pas dans le game pas si proche je
prends du roi quand même je suis pas
dans le game voilà c'est lui qui les
problèmes de connexion tu qu'on va de
nouveau devoir changer d'adversaire
parce que lui c'est pas mettre quelqu'un
en pls quand il n'a pas de connexion
assez chiant en fait elle que deux
coaches coach et qu'on a bien mis en pl
est bon mais là le pauvre il a pas de
connexion non mais ok ça ça
malheureusement
enfin pas de chance quoi pas de chance
hop hop hop
j'ai presque envie de lui faire des
trucs un peu bof quoi comme il n'a pas
de connexion j'ai envie de lui laisser
une chance de faire un match tu vois
faire un truc chevaleresque tu as julhes
son shot peut-être il va gagner tu en
sais pas je laisse une chance qu'il
puisse y avoir un match qu'ils trouvent
qu'ils traînent ou quoi les moulages
également il te prendre la 3ème parce
que voilà malheureusement tapas de mâcon
ton nom mais j'avais envie de coller
c'est ta chance tu vois j'ai envie de
lui laisser sa chance
non mais tu as raison qui ce qui n'a
aucun intérêt
bon allez il nous faut fair et du gros
poisson la tâche prend le tapis souris
d'ailleurs assez de nouveau lui l'a
toujours pas de connexion
aïe aïe aïe on n'a pas d'adversaire sa
patoche là ce soir
on n'arrive pas
on n'arrive pas à les tontons on n'y
arrive pas aïe aïe aïe
non mais là le mec on peut pas
l'accabler ça c'est vraiment un problème
de connexion n'enrichit pas trouvé les
bons adversaires bon at il un mec qui
prend g41 courage je ferais tu peux
essayer de faire du damas quatre échecs
et du chopper sont fous ça m'est déjà
arrivé en bullet
on va essayer de construire ça ça
bizarrement c'est nîmes qui existe j'ai
regardé j'ai un peu analyse avec
l'ordinateur et ça va tout à fait pour
les noirs d'ailleurs faut le savoir
faut le savoir
pas très bon pas très beau bateau à quel
jeu joue avec des six parce que je peux
jouer avec quelque 4,5 après avoir moi
je garde mon pull en d6 bien placé
ok
ok c'est de contraindre son pib quatre
là on n'a pas tant à ses débuts il est
aujourd'hui je me suis un peu endormi la
caisse pas grave ça sera pas
l'impression que son cavalier avec bien
loin en fait ça ressemble quand je vais
faire flipper un attentant j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup trop longtemps mais je vous
prends ces trois là dessus et je protège
ma tour fait quand même très très
attention
bon allez
ah je pensais kipré move bayan sûr il
veut pas rejouer d'un wc c'est
l'hécatombe aujourd'hui les mecs c'est
l'hécatombe
allez
il me joue un truc que j'aime pas trop
oui je me suis même mis à jouer normal
en fait pas une position de top top
ok on va pousser à fond
pour maître international ça mérite
olalalala oh là là le coquin le coquinou
le coquinou à c'était beau ça à tonton
bravo lorie là il m'a fait rêver il m'a
fait rêver avec ce petit caillou et cinq
échecs qui m'a fait rêver je te respecte
asetek aucun c'était beau nathalie sbaï
chorale l'autre côté at on fait gaffe
car ça fait quand même très très
attention à ce que tu fais quoi nîmes a
complètement défoncé en fait je fais
complètement de la merde boumal est fini
de plaisante et non mais il a gagné mon
respect avec sa petite tactique de
coquines ou si fait cai province un qui
gagne tout mon respect d'une force mais
si le fait pas malheureusement parce que
parce que l'arrêt mais bon c'est trop
tard ah c'est dommage c'est dommage
aliens cowboys tu pouvais gagner tout
mon respect en disant qu'elle prendrait
cinq plus tôt as tu m'as déçue il m'a
déçu
il m'a déçu aliens il m'a déçu je suis
désolé de te le dire
excuse moi pour te le dire comme dirait
vlad
merde
c'est pas si grave ce n'est qu'un fou
quoi
enfin le roi de la grob à troyes b 4 du
coup la dame va arrivant à peut-être si
les changes cette fantastique non ça
c'est génial
il y en a tellement de partout sur
l'échiquier c'est fantastique c'est
magnifique
j'ai quasi envie de claquer quelque
chose dans ces mauvaises idées je vais
garder ça là à mohamed salah coiffe ou
de partout voire vous ramez je peux pas
le maté la cavalière h3 [ __ ] c'est
beau quoi c'est tellement harmonieux là
ce que je suis en train de faire grâce
et de l'harmonie en branche
ah ils échangent les dames il ajou petit
je protège
c'est chaud
presse avec mes pièces sont sans grande
harmonie quoi donc automatiquement c'est
vrai que je crée énormément de menaces
quoi
mais quand tu es super harmonieux tu tu
fais mal quoi
je me suis maintenant en f1 aïe aïe aïe
j'étais trop harmonieux j'étais trop
harmonieux ben j'ai senti alors
pas évident cette position a abandonné
trop d'harmonie alors tentez une grave
n'ait eu les résistances et adversaires
bon
hop ça va le faire
on va les faire grand roque
nous les défions
je veux nous faire des pions double on
s'en fout total c'est un peu le concept
m7 hyperdangereux la merde
je crois que ça marche je crois que j'ai
tant de faire tout reprend g7 et du
chopper sa tour avec une enfilade
mais je suis pas sûr qu'elle j'ai pensé
que j'avais poussé 5 et que j'avais le
temps d'aller faire damage 7
je suis pas sûr que ça marche
je crois que ça marche pas les mecs ont
ils le voient pas fantastique il a fallu
que l'équipe france et 5 génial hockey
et qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde ce sera
une réussite pour moi
les cavaliers de caïds et deux échecs un
idiot mais on a réussi à faire le truc
fun et c'est passé ok l'abandonner qu'on
veut de manière plus pragmatique on peut
faire des grob mais tout tout dans tout
dans le doser quoi sénégal cncas
syndicale ça sent la pls ça sent la paix
risque au smic
les partis c'est complètement n'importe
quoi c'est génial ça ne veut absolument
rien dire c'est génial ça n'a aucun
rapport avec les échecs c'est
complètement spatiale c'est exactement
ce qu'on veut peut-être se rend pas
compte il complètement en train de
rentrer dans notre piège quoi on va te
bloque avec laurent leroy est un
excellent bloqueur fait attention est en
train de se faire dominer
intellectuellement en fait sans s'en
rendre compte il en train de se faire
dominer intellectuellement on va on va
lui pourrir le cerveau à lui croit le
pauvre c'est triste
trop jeune pour que ça lui arrive ce
genre de choses
c'est tellement du cac à ce qu'on est en
train de faire praia tour g7 je crois ah
non mince mince mince à un ton près ça
passait pas nécessaire on est en train
lui détruire le cerveau on est en train
de réussir
c'est génial c'est génial dommage je
peux avoir gagné la précédente soirée à
accélérer le processus de destruction
mais là il est clair que le mec qu'on
peu plus loin c'est sûr c'est beaucoup
trop con tout ce qu'on fait c'est génial
je vais faire grand roque c'est
fantastique
je suis tellement heureux
c'est génial ça veut rien dire les
partis c'est magnifique ça veut
absolument rien dire
on se marre avec le roi on se barre de
l'autre côté c'est génial j'adore
mince on n'y arrive pas à quoi on n'aura
pas c'est moi qui ai raté cette pièce
c'est moi qu'ils aient raté là on n'a
plus aucune chance le mec le mec est en
confiance et on réussira pas le réussira
pas à le détruire
mais bon bravo à lui il s'en est bien
tiré
il faut reconnaître
j'en ignore malheureusement
effacer complètement génial je lui donne
le pion à vii mais je vais essayer de de
faire des trucs marrants le quai à
angers 2 quand même
alors on va le faire chier c'est
vraiment ridicule puisque je suis alors
bon il n'a plus de temps qu est ce que
ça à le faire rejouer
allez on va on va recommencer on va
essayer de haas était pas le bon coussin
je me suis planté moi même dans ma
propre robe ça c'est pas mal joué de sa
part de ramener le cavalier jusqu'ici
mais bon va le chasser
on est très mal on va donner notre fou a
donné le fou de la grob
il a anticipé décatoire cavalli qui
reste sans pris soin donné le pion b est
un peu tous qui a attaqué mais on va
rajouter du bordel au bordel haye adam
preuve de dame prend des quatre aussi va
faire petit rouquin
on est un peu obligé après 1
mais ça va on a survécu et pas n'importe
qui et qui protège et non il est pas le
cavalier à l'époque on va faire f 4
je pense que le concept sa rente de
jouer le coup le plus ridicule possible
double échec
honnêtement ça rendu très heureux de
faire ce double échec
ça m'a rendu très heureux de faire ce
double échec qui servait à rien mais ça
m'a rendu heureux car mon objectif quand
même d'être heureux quand on vous du
coup objectif rempli
très heureux de ce double échec maman
c'est quelque part à l'apogée de ma
carrière froid et fuite
ça y est c'est tous les coups sont en
train de rentrer là d'une puissance mais
de feu quoi
c'est en train d'être magnifique là
même pas lui prendre sa pièce quoi c'est
une forme de non respect on lui a même
pas pris son camaïeu 6 quoi
rail ne prend pas nos pièces non [ __ ]
[ __ ] il est fort quoi
voilà genre j'ai l'impression d'un genre
de ce milieu pas
je ne sait plus sur quel pied danser
quoi c'est une partie de génie qu'on est
en train de faire c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre 1 personne n'a
pris les pièces des autres ces
fantastiques magnifiques comme parti à
c'était beau non franchement les mecs
c'était bon
principe à quoi faire
moi je donne mon foulard rome
allez on va échanger les dames pour une
fois on va se laisser doubler les pions
puisque c'est dans l'esprit on va se
dédoubler fait très attention
je voulais mais tour là ça me fera des
vacances va faire kg catoire remettre
les pieds dans l'ordre maintenant
problèmes de connexion ses revenus bon
alors là poussant avec les pions sur la
couleur de notre fou
grâce à la connexion qui flanche là
500 qui craque
c'est le sens qu'il est en train de
craquer une nouvelle fois
c'est moi qui craque
non c'est pas moi qui craque c'est lui
qui craquent aller mais c'est pas une
vraie paix à l'est cela qu'on est en
train de faire malheureusement même si
on mène au score ou quoi c'est pas une
vraie paix à l'aise quand il faut
reconnaître je remets mon foie sans sa
case départ attention allez hop hop hop
hop
alors
qu'est ce que ça vaut cette petite
position
mettez moi je dis moi ça va pièce de
plus belle ouverture pour les noirs ça
joue bien
mon avis ça joue bien pour le moment
après quelques petites nouveautés
théorique sorti au début
après ça m'embête toujours un petit peu
de sortir mais mais nouveauté mais bon
on est aussi obligé
la fin ça perd ça
ça c'est mauvais aussi que d'erreurs
a on s'est fait mal tourner aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe bon mais c'est un fier
adversaires on peut être un peu on peut
être fier de lui il se bat à fond il est
partout il se sera pas arrêté est tout
près on sent qu'il veut quand même
prendre les pièces et où la précédence
devrait elle pas avoir gagné après une
telle ouverture bas comme une pièce de
moins pour le moment
j'ai peur qu'on n'arrive pas à grand
chose là j'arrive pas ouvrir la position
pour aller les pièces c'est de la merde
dégage
travail halfway f4 qui tombe
ouais mais là on est mal
on peut même plus jouer là c'est
horrible
bon
arrivé bon ma foi là pour une fois qu'on
fait ça sans que ce soit si mauvais ça
pourrait te donner entourant le pion non
mais je crois qu'il est quand même pas
loin de 2 complètement craqué
mentalement le mec ce sera une semi
réussite
on leur a pas mis en pl ace dans le sens
j'aurais pas assez bien joué pour mais
je pense qu'il va avoir du mal à jouer
aux échecs pendant quelques jours pour
en tout cas quelque partie tout du moins
je pense quand même qu'on a fait de son
cerveau de la bouillie chansons qu'il ne
sait absolument plus qu il en train de
jouer ce qu'il faut faire
je le sens plein règle régression
mentale
je sens qu'il est mal
j'avais d'alger sans cacher que j'ai
raté qui était assez fort ajoutez-y
français 2 g dames e3 je rate tous là
moi aussi j'ai un coup de pompe
mais l'union le troll on fait une partie
complètement normal à la prochaine mais
on fait un truc complètement normal à la
prochaine je suis un système de londres
et où un des trucs les plus insipides
qui va être dégoûté il va être
complètement dégoûté c'est tellement une
évidence que ça l'fait super chier ils
poussent les pions et où il est
complètement hors cei au lieu des frais
non lus échanges toutes les pièces et
tout on échange tout on essaye de jouer
truc le plus ennuyeux possible non
sacrifie rien ces chutes sont écoutés
c'est génial j'ai un truc positionnelle
et où on lui change les dames
mais c'est évident que ça fait super
chier
je le vois c'est qu'on la trouve géniale
c'est tellement évident que ça le fait
chier bon
mais je vais quand même pas mal c'est la
méchante elle permet
pas mal joué quand même mais c'est sûr
qu'ils aient complètement dégoûté il est
complètement dégoûté c'est évident ah
mince je perds je perds ça ah je dois
mieux qu'un méchant nain mais qu'est ce
que c'est ridicule
or le fait quand même tombé mais bon
c'était pas drôle on l'a joué normal
maintenant
c'est génial c'est fantastique
à
cf 5 f 4 jusqu'à 1000 française à
l'envers en fait j'ai gardé mon casse
blanche
c'est mon mauvais où je le garde dégage
mais je t'attaque et roja fait attention
même ramené le cahier vert 4
mon pêcheur qui allait devenir par ici
on va les créer des faiblesses de
l'autre côté
l'entité chèque
que je vais afghane ne pas me faire
contre attaqué par contre
mais c'est génial
c'est tellement beau de faire ça c'est
tellement le truc ultime
maintenant tu joues normal tout est
parti c'est fini quoi tu n'auras plus
avoir une partie marrante c'est fini ça
être que de la merde maintenant ça être
que des trucs super chiant il a pu avoir
une partie drôle et tout assez génial
toutes les parties vont être ainsi pi de
l'ennuyeuse on va tout échange un
maximum ou l'eau tu te fasses fier je
veux même pas spécialement bien la
finale mais bon l'intérêt c'est juste
que la partie soit la plus ferme est
possible nettoyant efficace mais le fou
en f1 l'objectif c'est que tu te fasses
yeux
j'ai vraiment changé mon fusil d'épaulé
bon par contre que je fasse quelque
chose quand même
parce que là c'est malin ce qu'on a
c'est très mauvais ce que j'ai fait de a
à z
on va se faire mater mince bon j'ai
voulu faire un truc ennuyeuse sans bien
jouer c'est dommage
non mais c'est clair qu'on lui a
complètement déformé le cerveau mais bon
c'était drôle au début c'était très
drôle maintenant quoi laisser revenir à
bien jouer et à jouer normalement moi
j'ai un peu de mal on a juste une
mauvaise position une nouvelle fois
à
hu a pas mal joué de match parce que je
fais j'en ai un peu marre honnêtement
aïe aïe aïe c'est d'arriver à 10 on va
aller chez cet adversaire on aura perdu
un coup de poing mais bon ce sera bien
amusé n'aura pas vraiment réussi à faire
l'appel est ce qu'on souhaitait mais bon
c'était pas évident aussi puisque d'un
autre côté on a beaucoup changé les
adversaires et du coup c'est pas facile
quoi on est on est sur des bons
adversaires au début mais ils se sont
vite écarté quoi
j'ai en train de dire le chat un peu en
même temps
donc j'ai pas ce que voulait voir pour
les prochains stream si ce que vous avez
préféré les trucs pédagogique y
entraînent leurs tactiques les pls un
peu de tout
n'hésitez pas à écrire un petit mot
n'hésitez pas à écrire un petit mot hrw
fulham a mais je paie sa grande utilité
bon allez vous le faire tomber
on sai s'y attendait parce que je prenne
sa tour est ce qu'on doit un match ans
et une conque links crochard je sais pas
je ne vois pas trop traîner sur tuer ce
point comme keynes crochard j'ai
l'impression qu'il a trop peur j'ai
l'impression que la peur l'a envahi
alors est ce qu'on a perdu une pièce
dans cette histoire oui est-ce que c'est
grave non on s'en fout total on va
laisser attaquer un peu on va voir ce
qui donne
moi j'aurais fait du fou prend à vii
tempo rhin depuis tout à l'heure là
quand même
complètement gagnant mais bon est-ce
qu'il va réussir vraiment à faire une
attaque de maths ou pas on va lui
prendre son pion déjà pas vraiment il
rentre dans la finale la gagnante mais
ne joue pas le pana juge ou pas le beau
jeu sérieux alors c'est pas un
adversaire qui nous avait plu mais bon
j'ai un fond qu'il a perdu son panache
et ses yeux cette finale alors ce que ça
donne
ouais c'est pas le panache ça
ban avait été puni par ton manque de
panache il a même perdu dans le
franchement franchement est-ce que tu as
le droit de perdre ça honnêtement
honnêtement ça me gêne tu vois je
presque envie de la laisser gagner tu
vois l'histoire deux souhaitent théorie
construction en train de jouer c'est
génial
boum grand roc ca ces théories ça dégage
non mais quasi ça me gêne la dernière
jeudi quasi parce qu'en fait ça me gêne
pas du tout un maire quasi quoi presque
est-ce qu'on peut s'amuser et la
dernière du jour
est-ce qu'on peut s'amuser c'est à dire
sacrifier une dame
ouais mais le problème c'est qu'ils me
la rend tout de suite c'est désagréable
c'est désagréable
découpez les en et du canal
j'ai envie d'en faire une de plus pour
finir sur un truc plus au bon là je lui
laisse du matos pour me faire plaisent
j'aurais pu lui refaire ou apprendre et
faire la même chose après mais j'ai
envie de me faire plaisir et le de le
martyriser avec le pion là bas bon allez
sans mérite une dernière bon il donne
pas de rush
dommage dommage dommage dommage on était
pas loin d'eux j'aurais pu faire mieux
j'aurais pu faire mieux et discuter mais
qu'un désolé
désolé les mecs
ouais c'était c'était pas si loin où là
il rejoue
non c'est en ladder je pensais pas
écrire au jour et mais bon
le riz match et ai été été lancé
c'est génial comme parti c'est
magnifique
ça j'avais calculé déjà
je peux pas vraiment faire ce que je
veux un parti pris sans et se faire
chier simple à peut-être tic ou
intermédiaire sympa tosh
mais on va le faire tomber un
malheureusement
question de faire pour le troll est bon
un peu trop les à la fin mais bon il est
trop lent pas assez rapide que l'un des
tactiques il est trop mou du genou donc
est ce qui est écrit dans le tchad je
vois plus trop eu un petit mot wade
avait lentement de la pls laver un truc
a bien aimé ce double échec aussi qu'il
a fait c'était la confusion d'une vie
mais sur son cas plus personne qui parle
dans le chat bon rat c'était marrant
évidemment à prendre sur le ton de
l'humour même si je j'ai vu dans l'autre
chat en anglais que pat monde comprend
le second degré mais bon nous ne sommes
pas tous nous ne sommes pas tous ceux en
capacité d'avoir ce cette possibilité
dommage avant ce compagne c'est du
second degré bravo à vous je vous
félicite et sur ce je vous souhaite à
tous une bonne soirée merci d'avoir
suivi et à bientôt
ciao ciao